A
SYSTEMICALLY RACIST AND ROTTEN
AND EVIL COUNTRY.
THANK YOU, BOTH OF YOU, TONIGHT.
THERE WAS A JARRING COMMENT FROM
CONGRESSWOMAN ESCOBAR ON
GREETING KAMALA HARRIS AT THE
EL PASO AIRPORT TODAY.
>> WELCOME TO MY COMMUNITY
COMMITTED THE NEW ELLIS ISLAND,
I HAVE A HEART FULL OF GRATITUDE
BECAUSE WE FINALLY HAVE AN
ADMINISTRATION WILLING TO TACKLE
THE BIG CHALLENGES, WILLING TO
TACKLE CHALLENGES IN A
MEANINGFUL, THOUGHTFUL,
STRATEGIC, COMPASSIONATE WAY AND
UNDERSTANDING WHAT IS DRIVING
PEOPLE FROM THEIR HOMES, WHAT'S
MAKING THEM ARRIVE AT OUR
NATION'S FRONT DOOR.
>> Laura: JOINING ME NOW,
VICTOR DAVID HANSON, THE ELLIS
ISLAND OF 2021.
TEE OFF ON THAT FOR A MOMENT.
>> EVERY ELEMENT OF THAT
COMPARISON IS PATHETIC, LAURA.
ELLIS ISLAND, EVERYBODY CAME
LEGALLY.
1890 TO 1924, IT WAS ILLEGAL AND
THEY CAME, THEY WERE ALL
AUDITED.
PEOPLE COMING ACROSS THE
RIO GRANDE, ESPECIALLY AT
EL PASO AND THE STATE OF TEXAS
ARE COMING FOR THE MOST PART
ILLEGALLY.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY IDEA IN THE
MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC WHETHER
THEY HAVE BEEN VACCINATED,
PROBABLY NOT, OR WHETHER THEY
ARE ACTIVE CARRIERS.
5,000 CUSTOM OFFICERS HAVE BEEN
INFECTED.
THEY WERE DIVERSE AT ELLIS
ISLAND.
THEY CAME FROM ALL OVER THE
WORLD.
THIS IS ONE GROUP OF SPANISH
SPEAKING PEOPLE.
IT'S NOT DIVERSE LIKE ELLIS
ISLAND.
AND THEY CAME WITH THE
EXPECTATION TO ASSIMILATE
RAPIDLY, TO INTEGRATE,
INTERMARRY.
THAT IS NOT THE MESSAGE WE ARE
GIVING THESE IMMIGRANTS ARE
COMING ILLEGALLY.
WE ARE TELLING THEM THEY ARE
PART OF A TRIBAL IDENTITY, IT IS
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN AMERICA AND
PEOPLE FORGET ABOUT ELLIS
ISLAND.
IT WAS MEASURED.
I KNOW SOME DAYS, THEY MAY HAVE
HAD FIVE OR 6,000 BUT OVER THE
36 YEAR PERIOD THERE WAS ABOUT
12 MILLION PEOPLE WHO ARRIVED
HERE.
WE ARE GETTING UP TO 2 MILLION
SO WE ARE GETTING SIX TO SEVEN
TIMES MORE PER YEAR ACROSS THE
SOUTHERN BORDER THAN WE DID
THROUGH ELLIS ISLAND.
EVERY ELEMENT OF THAT COMPARISON
IS JUST FACTUALLY WRONG AND IT'S
KIND OF INSULTING TO THE PEOPLE
WHO FOLLOW THE RULES.
GRANDPARENTS OR
GREAT-GRANDPARENTS OR PARENTS
THAT DID THAT.
IT'S REALLY SICKENING.
>> Laura: MY GRANDPARENTS ON
MY MOM'S SIDE CAME THROUGH ELLIS
ISLAND AND I REMEMBER HEARING
SOME OF THOSE DISTANT STORIES.
IT TOOK MY BREATH AWAY, THAT
COMPARISON.
I WANT TO PLAY SOMETHING ELSE
THAT HARRIS SAID AT THE BORDER.
>> I STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT ONCE
PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO LEAVE HOME
AND WHEN THEY DO, IT IS BECAUSE
EITHER THEY ARE FLEEING FROM
HARM OR BECAUSE TO STAY MEANS
THAT THEY CANNOT PROVIDE THE
BASIC NECESSITIES FOR THEIR
FAMILY.
>> Laura: THAT DOESN'T QUALIFY
THEM FOR STATUS IN THE
UNITED STATES, SHE DOESN'T EVEN
KNOW THE LAW AND SHE IS
SUPPOSEDLY THIS GREAT LAWYER.
THAT IS NOT PERSECUTION UNDER
ONE OF THE GREAT CAUSES LISTED
UNDER THE ASYLUM STATUTE.
>> THAT'S ALSO ALIVE.
WE HAVE LOOPHOLES TAKEN
FREQUENTLY AND IN MEXICO ALONE,
50% OF THE MEXICAN POPULATION
SAYS GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY THEY
WOULD MOVE TO THE UNITED STATES
IMMEDIATELY.
HALF THE COUNTRY, 55 MILLION
PEOPLE WOULD COME.
IF YOU OPEN THE BORDERS, ALL OF
CENTRAL AMERICA AND MEXICO WOULD
COME BECAUSE FOR ALL THE
CRITICISM OF AMERICA, WE ARE A
CONSTITUTIONAL STATE WITH
INDIVIDUAL LIBERTY AND WHAT KIND
OF ALLOW PEOPLE TO BE
PROSPEROUS, SECURE AND HAPPY IN
A WAY THAT IS IMPOSSIBLE IN
THEIR HOMELAND, SO THEY WOULD
ALL COME AND YET THAT IS THE BIG
DISCONNECT.
THE LEFT SAYS THIS IS A TERRIBLE
COUNTRY AND YET THEY CAN'T
EXPLAIN WHY EVERYBODY WANTS TO
COME TO A RACIS